well at 6 14 as you can see on your
screen there we have hector mejia in the
middle of debauchery more crowds
returning to las vegas
restrictions are loosening up here on st
patrick's day yeah business is hoping to
cash in for st
patrick's day for the first time in two
years now of course this is a huge day
for bars
all right so let's check in with our
lucky charm hector mejia live on fremont
street
with a green pig and a bunch of other
random stuff hector good morning to you
oh my goodness isn't this crazy all
right so we're gonna light it up so
we're gonna go ahead and light this up
this is actually a green colored pig as
you can tell
obviously but this is just part of the
offerings here at project bbq
isn't this great rob oh yeah this is our
favorite day of the year
we uh we absolutely want invite
everybody down
bring your mask we're going to try to
stay social distance the best we can
we got uh green tacos the green hog
extravaganza
and the cheer squad out there too we
absolutely do
so tell us about how it's centered guys
welcome back people for after
you know so long well i mean it's been
two years so we uh
we're really excited that we get to do
this this year it's raining gold coin
oh yes absolutely all day long so this
is crazy what's the uh process
and what does it take to put this
together and are you guys selling this
today
just one or many no we have many we're
limited so get your orders in
i already have one what's that we
already have one order in yeah we have
one order since this morning so
we gotta we got a couple more to go and
uh just give us a call and
we'll place your order in time so we've
seen green colored rivers we've seen
green beer
green tacos how'd you come up with the
idea with a green pig
you know we've been down here four years
and meet a lot of people
this little irishman came up and uh he
told us hey this is what you should do
and gave us a recipe and uh
man did it work did it work all right so
we asked
earlier uh what does this pig taste but
for you
how would you describe it actually we
came up with a name this is little ricky
yeah little ricky's this one you'll get
to name your pig and
we can definitely post whatever you guys
come up with
still tastes like chicken or for you
more like shrimp or what no no no i'm a
pork fan so it tastes exactly like it
should
juicy that's great a juicy green colored
cake
with some candles on it oh this is our
twist to bottle service you know
we everybody likes to be seen and get
your pictures taken so
we'll bring it out we blow horns
whistles got our cheers staffed right
behind us and uh
absolutely will you be seen out on the
street
and i really can't sense that you guys
are excited oh yeah this is this is
great
uh two years in the in the making here
uh one more thing you guys also have
green tacos
oh yeah so uh chef rex or my partner
will be uh
showing you guys a little later how to
how to make the green tacos and uh
it's a green tortilla oh green tortilla
yes
and we got a spin on that we're gonna uh
probably raffle some things off for
every order we'll give a raffle ticket
and
give you guys something by the end of
the day awesome thank you so much for
having us all right you guys so look at
this just
look at it we'll try not to look at it
directly
in the face we actually covered the
eyeballs with these uh
coins may i oh pardon me so uh yeah so
we have these
whoops but you can just see just look at
them it just looks
delicious i mean yum yum yum yum yum
right oh yeah
i mean this is this is what people like
to do come out enjoy
celebrate st patrick's day out here on
fremont in front of circa
across from golden gate so awesome thank
you very much all right well reporting
live hector mejia
back to you guys hector do not look at
him in the face
excited
we've heard of irish stout and little
ricky is an irish
snout oh my god